at a seattle lgbt pride month
called taking black pride taking b
in parentheses l a c k pride
uh if you're if you're white you have to
pay more money
they're charging a reparations fee
they say ten dollars to fifty dollars to
keep the event free of cost
for black and brown trans
and queer people that's pretty narrow
how many black and brown trans and queer
people are there
two capitol hill pride organizers
complained and the seattle human rights
commission blast
human what the human rights commission
what is that blasted them on social
media
for complaining about charging white
people more money than black people
and uh included their unredacted phone
number and came out
the human rights commission decided to
dox people and put them in harm's
way they got
knocked for doing this now you're going
to see this more and more you were
openly seeing the talk of quote-unquote
reparations
which is not it's not really reparat
first of all we've already had
reparations in this country for a very
long time that's that was the entire
purpose
of the great society and the welfare
programs was to make reparation
for slavery a century prior
but it's not really reparations and this
wouldn't be reparations either because
that wouldn't be the end
you're telling me that okay we're gonna
we're gonna have a big reparations fund
and we're gonna give all the black
people
some money and we're probably going to
give other races some money why i don't
know but that's being talked about
and we're going to give recent nigerian
immigrants some money from who from just
white people how are you going to do
that in the tax code i'm not sure
and okay let's say you do it and then
we're all good right then it's totally
fine
uh something tells me that's not what's
going to happen
this is not just being enforced this
this racial caste system this
highly racial ideology is not just being
enforced at
the local level of some kooky
pride parades or something this is being
enforced by the government that's what
affirmative action is it disadvantages
whites and asians and it gives advantage
to blacks and hispanics
in college admissions and elsewhere
hands up don't nuke
that is the subject of the entire show
i'm glad you like that clip you can
watch the entire show here on youtube
it's titled hands up don't nuke you can
also get it at apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play spotify myspace
xanga live journal
you can also get my book it is out as of
two days ago speechless controlling
words controlling minds get it wherever
you get your books
subscribe smash the like button we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you